die Flutkatastrophe im Aartal 14 Wochen
ist es ja dass die Wassermassen alles
mit sich rissen und Tod und Verwüstung
zurückließen ja unsere Reporter Peter
hell der
war mehr Katastrophengebiet und hat eine
beeindruckende Reportage gedreht und
jemand ein kurzer Ausschnitt
sind sich Rheinland-Pfalz 14 Wochen nach
der Flutkatastrophe immer noch sind die
Spuren der Verwüstung allgegenwärtig
seit der Katastrophe ist Gutachter Mike
Menke als Sachverständiger für
Gebäudeschäden unterwegs ja momentan was
man hier so vorfindet ist ein Bild der
Zerstörung und des Grauens sieht aus wie
in einem Kriegsgebiet überall tiefe
Löcher Einschläge Spuren an den
Hauswänden Krater in den
Straßen
überall liegt Müll rum es ist wirklich
grausam was man hier so sieht das sieht
aus wie nach dem Bombenangriff hier
am 15 juli hält ein Anwohner mit seinem
Handy fest wie die drei Meter hohe
Flutwelle der a alles mitreißt die
Wohnungen im Erdgeschoss werden zerstört
die Bewohner können rechtzeitig fliehen
fühlen sie sich denn von den Behörden so
ein bisschen im Stich gelassen
[Musik]
das hätte ich mal die Regierung unter
mir
und ich behauptet deshalb ist es überall
Warmwasser Heizung
die Jahrhundertflut hat nicht nur
tausende Wohnungen und Häuser zerstört
sondern auch die Strom und
Versorgungsleitung was befürchten sie
für den Winter hier jetzt bei diesem
Haus zum Beispiel Leute fangen an machen
Feuer in den Wohnungen die Leute frieren
die Leute wissen nicht wohin die Leute
werden hier vermutlich andere Maßnahmen
aufziehen um irgendwie Wärme in ihre
Wohnung zu kriegen ich will mir gar
nicht ausmalen was hier im Winter
passiert
Wohnung wurde durch die Flut zerstört
eine Nachbarin überließ ihr und den
Kindern dann ihre Wohnung doch die hat
ebenfalls flugschäden
ja womit sollen wir uns Wärme außer mit
Decken zu und Jacken leider ansonsten
ohne Strom funktioniert
[Musik]
mit Jacken und bei Kerzenlicht wieder
hell der die Reportage gedreht hat ist
jetzt bei uns im Studio die Bilder haben
wir gesehen aber was sind deine
persönlichen Eindrücke naja die
Eindrücke sind so das was wir gesehen
haben also man kommt wenn man ins Ahrtal
fährt in ein Katastrophengebiet einigen
geht es gut den ist geholfen worden die
haben sich sehr selber helfen können es
ist eine irrsinnige Solidarität unter
den Anwohnern auch aber manchen geht es
immer noch sehr schlecht wir haben das
gerade gesehen es ist auch nicht nur das
physische also das ist kein Strom gibt
das ist teilweise kein Wasser gibt immer
noch nicht sondern es sind auch die
psychischen Belastungen wir haben es
gesehen die die Leute sind durch muss
man sagen und jetzt ist die riesige
Angst vor dem Winter also es gibt nach
Temperaturen die gehen jetzt Richtung
Null einige Wohnungen wie wir gesehen
haben haben immer noch keinen Strom
immer noch kein Gas keine Heizung es
sollen bis Ende November sollen 2500
Wohnungen etwa mit Gas ausgestattet
werden von 3.500 also da fehlen immer
noch viele machen und
wir haben gesehen die Menschen weinen
sie sind verzweifelt teilweise und wenn
es dann wir waren in Wohnung da ist war
es jetzt schon 14 13 14 Grad mit der
jungen Mutter da haben wir 14 Grad
gemessen die müssen wirklich tatsächlich
mit Decken abends da sitzen und
Hausaufgaben machen und da tut sich noch
nicht aber Peter was ist deiner Meinung
nach schief gelaufen also ich meine dass
der Winter jetzt kommt ist klar naja was
heißt schief gelaufen es ist eine
irrsinnige Katastrophe gewesen wir
wissen Deutschland ist ein ein blühendes
Bürokratie Land bevor irgendetwas
passiert müssen Anträge geschrieben
werden die Verantwortlichkeiten werden
von A nach B geschoben wir haben mit
Leuten gesprochen die haben gesagt wir
schaffen es auch gar nicht die Formulare
auszufüllen da braucht man Pilotenschein
für also das ist und dann muss man auch
sagen viele Menschen haben auch
Sprachschwierigkeiten es sind Migranten
die dort wohnen teilweise die können das
gar nicht lesen und jetzt versucht man
so langsam höher als die
Verantwortlichkeiten auch zu
kanalisieren es passiert jetzt was aber
es die höchste Zeit ist muss jetzt was
gemacht werden weil der Winter steht vor
der Tür und es fehlen immer noch für
mehrere hundert Haushalte fehlt Strom
Wasser und wir haben auch was auch in
der Reportage ist die Leute versorgen
sich teilweise selber das heißt sie
haben
Heizstäbe in in den Wassertanks das was
lebensgefährlich ist das offene
Stromleitung dort in den Badezimmer sind
wo eben provisorisch versucht wird das
Wasser warm zu machen und das ist
natürlich lebensgefährlich sowas wird er
jetzt gibt es ja 30 Milliarden Euro die
von der Bundesregierung zur Verfügung
gestellt werden zum Teil auch von den
Ländern und du hast vorhin gesagt es
gibt einige denen geht es gut aber
andere eben nicht wie wir hier gesehen
haben woran liegt das warum kriegen die
einen ein halbwegs normales Leben wieder
hin und andere nicht
sehr gute Farben auch schwer zu
beantworten es ist immer in der Sache
der Verantwortlichkeiten zum Beispiel
ein Eigentümer der ein Wohnhaus besitzt
ist dann teilweise auch verantwortlich
für die Wasserversorgung oder auch für
die Stromversorgung da sagt das Land du
bist verantwortlich dafür dann dauert
das natürlich wieder wir haben ein Haus
eine Reportage in diesem Haus gemacht wo
der Eigentümer verschwunden ist er hatte
vorher erst seinen Mietern gekündigt
also das hängt dann teilweise auch an
den an den Eigentümern und dann hört die
Verantwortlichkeit von den Behörden dann
teilweise auch auf und die sagen okay
dafür ist dann der Eigentümer zuständig
und das ist eben die Koks an der Sache
also ich will nicht ungerecht sein alle
versuchen das Beste die Bürokratie ist
hinderlich extrem die Formulare sind
teilweise extrem hinderlich und dann
eben die Divergenzen zwischen Eigentümer
und Regierung und Kommunen das müsste
besser laufen und ich befürchte dass es
da noch zu schlimm Engpässen kommt und
dann fragt sich natürlich auch wo sind
denn eigentlich die ganzen Spendengelder
vor allem auch dass die Menschen jetzt
in ihren Wohnungen sitzen und frieren
müssen gibt es da nicht die Möglichkeit
einer Notunterkunft oder die in
Apartments Hotels unterzubringen richtig
die gibt es und zwar in Ahrweiler wird
jetzt auch ein Containerdorf gebaut mit
etwa 144 Zimmern die haben etwa 12
Quadratmeter da ist ein WC drin da ist
ein Gemeinschaft eine Gemeinschaftsküche
auch ein Bad drin da kann man dann
alternativ hin ist aber immer noch nicht
die beste Lösung und
soweit man versucht jetzt eben viele
Leute sind natürlich auch privat bei
Verwandten immer noch aber es wird getan
ist eine irrsinnige Solidarität
untereinander die Spendengelder werden
auch verteilt wir haben Mike Menke
gesehen er ist Sachverständiger er hat
auch
gibt Elektroheizungen verteilt er zum
Beispiel oder eben auch Radiatoren dass
die Leute eben sich wehren können also
das wird schon gemacht es aber es ist
trotzdem ist man ahnt dass es zu
Engpässen kommen wird ist noch Luft nach
oben vielen Dank
dass du vor Ort nach dem Rechten
geschaut hast diese Bilder mitgebracht
hast damit wir sie alle sehen